[Musique]
cher père noël tu es le meilleur
tout ce que je veux c'est passer un
joyeux noël en compagnie d'une famille
qui m'aime je t'embrasse
peter albright peter
as tu termines et à m oui tenez là voici
parfait je l'enverrai au père noël dès
ce soir et peter je viens d'avoir ton
père au téléphone et je ne pense pas
qu'il viendra de chercher pourquoi
eh bien ils pensent que ce serait mieux
que tu restes avec nous pour toujours
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peter peter albright de la chaîne aux
biches vous poser une question
peter peter and hospital ça va bien vous
à la star peter hayes nouvelle chaîne
est juste une question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
peeters veut pas être filmé
[Musique]
bouger
peter albright quel est votre meilleur
souvenir de la journée une migraine
s'il vous plaît est-ce que huit heures
[ __ ] le bail de la chaîne 12 peter
white de la chaîne aux vous avez dépensé
beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui place au
jeune âge les volets
pas de chance on pourrait pas changer de
sujet du reportage cette année tu
proposes quoi on pourrait parler de
l'augmentation du nombre de suicides
la grande déprime de l'aele guirlandes
sapins est comprimé ou un sujet sur les
père noël des grands magasins sont-ils
blancs comme neige
je propose qu'on recherche ce qui ont un
casier judiciaire en période de fêtes on
peut pas ennuyer les gens avec des
sujets aussi glauque
je t'en prie georges pour une fois j'ai
envie de prouver que je peux faire du
vrai journalisme je veux tu t'en
tiennent à la folie des achats demeures
et recueilli aucun témoignage les gens
ne veulent pas me parler deguisetoi en
père noël
et pourquoi pas avec une caméra planqué
dans ma capuche et sa j'adore
tu me fais marcher c'est ton idée
c'était un exemple de ce qu'on pouvait
faire de plus exigé de noël vu à travers
les yeux du père noël
[Musique]
c'est parfait donc il ne voulait pas me
ridiculiser c'est réussi
la prochaine fois je tiendrai ma langue
[Musique]
ça fonctionne tient la tête plus droite
je tiens d un toit est temps qu'elle
excusez moi mademoiselle mais vous
apparaissez dans de nombreuses listes de
noël de grands garçons
je me demandais dont si je pouvais vous
embarquez vous emballé dans du papier
cadeau
peter des dogmes tirent profit je
suppose que les feuillages et demandé
dans la liste propos du fait d'un
déguisement et ben je suis en reportage
tu m'as reconnu tu crois que je me
laisserais draguer par le premier père
noël venu et je vois on dit toujours
ensemble ce soir
oui mais à condition que tout change
bonjour père noël je voudrais une poupée
mannequin y la maison qui va avec
bien sûr tu les auras mâché rue mais
attention je vais une maison de bar de
plage avec tous les équipements avec
jacuzzi un garage pour deux voitures
vers nos portes à une fausse garde il
faut pas toucher et aux réponses
t'es gentil à voir le père noël qu'eads
en kiosque il se verrait ses les moitiés
vais une décapotable euros c'est un 4/4
violet avec peinture métallisée tabac
info bide
cette année surtout n'oubliez pas mes
piles
quand je pense qu'il ya des gens qui ont
des enfants qui vivent chez eux par des
années c'est bon allez passez moi ta
main super où je vais trouver un père
noël maintenant on pourrait appeler à
l'agent artistique sûrement des acteurs
au chômage qui seront ravis de
travailler m mademoiselle très fière
j'espère que le père noël nous j'espère
que ça devrait bien se passer mais je
vois que vous avez vite trouver
quelqu'un pour le remplacer
c'est parfait non non je suis pas son
remplacement il n'en est pas si tu les
quelques heures le temps de trouver un
remplaçant ses traits si tu sais bien
que je suis maladroit avec aisance et le
te plaît peter ho c'est pas possible il
manquait plus que ça c'est le bouquet
passez suffit je m'en vais je dois
rentrer chez moi pour nourrir mes rennes
il désolé
ces droits seillant comme ça je t'en
prie et dis moi que tu m'as trouvé un
remplaçant tous les agents disent la
même chose c'est pas deux jours avant
noël qu'on peut trouver un bon père noël
v on va faire passer quelques auditions
tu as essayé le pana
allez la bnr nous sommes très en retard
sur le planning 5 gentiment sera pas
dans les déciment ilit en cisjordanie en
selle sortie via blue box 6000 ie9 gens
retournent tu es ce que tu as vu le boss
je crois pas tu devrais aller voir les
tables max je te remercie reprends ton
travail je ne t'ai pas dérangé non bon
d'accord
un gentil deux gentilles 3
gentil la vie de garçon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime pas ça vous êtes là je vous
chercher partout
est-ce que ça va quand les jugements tôt
pour la dernière fois
d'après les manches évasées je dirais
les années 60 et 70 il ya un problème
j'ai retrouvé ses lettres c'est dans une
poche intérieure les avait oubliés c'est
une faute professionnelle terrible et si
ça se trouve il y en a encore d'autres
tu te rends compte des lettres d'enfants
que j'ai oublié et qui sont au fond du
nord aujourd'hui ça ne pourrait plus
arriver ils savaient plus possible il ya
les emails des facs et internet
et oui mais autrefois les enfants
étaient moins exigeants il demandait un
vélo une luge défaut simple il disait
s'il vous plaît merci ils demandaient
parfois comme cadeau d'avoir un petit
frère ou une petite soeur à cette époque
les enfants demander des choses plus
sérieuses ils étaient moins gâtés mais
aujourd'hui tu vois c'est fini tout ce
qu'il c'est à dire ces jeux valve job
combien de lettres avons nous reçu cette
année et max non je n'en sais rien père
noël 5 6 700 millions à et pour autant
que je sache dans aucune de ces lettres
il n'y avait le moins de remercie pas un
merci sur toute la quantité vous ne
voyez pas une petite déprime
vous travaillez 3 non ce n'est pas moi
qui déraille c'est noël qui a déraillé
c'est devenu une industrie pur et dur
pas une seule commande qui dirait
pourrais-tu me faire plaisir ou est ce
que c'est vrai que maintenant noël c'est
devenu quelque chose de machines à lilia
plus message d'espoir cette magie tout
ça c'est fini
alors si ça continue je vais prendre ma
retraite je sens que je vais raccrocher
mort vous exagérez tous les ans c'est la
même histoire avec vous aux premiers
signes de déclin et voilà que vous êtes
prêt à vendre noël à une société de
catalogues de jouets monsieur
la vie c'est tous les ans la même
rengaine mais n'ont jamais de la vie si
tous les ans c'est pareil on se comprend
que décembre se soit pas à moi facile
mais reconnaissez le père noël c'est un
travail alors arrêtez de vous ronger les
ongles
je ne peux pas alors mettez vos gants il
faut que vous reteniez une chose c'est
que les enfants comptent sur vous c'est
important il ne faut jamais l'oublier
je le crois vraiment j'en suis sûr et
certain
vous souffrez du bonheur de la joie aux
enfants du monde entier regarde qui dans
le ciel c'est le père noël avec ses
cadeaux aller au travail maintenant
non non vas-y tout seul max je vais
aller faire un petit tour
l'histoire de me changer les idées je
vais très bien entendu
[Musique]
je lis façon de se débiner
ça vous dirait d'aller prendre l'air
mais honni ainsi on devait faire un
petit tour pour vous dérouiller les
jambes
et
ah je suis désolé pour le resto mais je
suis pas tranquille quand je sais que
les actes de georges c'est peter j'ai
une autre idée
les cadences infernales dans les usines
de jouets toute la vérité rappelle moi
et et ne dit pas non avant d'y avoir
réfléchi sérieusement pour moi
franchement tu déteste noël n'est ce pas
non pas vraiment mais dépenser autant
d'énergie d'argent durant un mois pour
un seul jour formulé autant d'espoirs de
rêve et d'attendre dans ce qui n'est
qu'une fête commerciale
ça ne peut que vous apportez un tas de
déceptions alors toi tu n'attends rien
de noël c'est ça pour moi noël n'est
qu'une vaste escroquerie ce que je
disais tu déteste noël oui ce serait
bien mal rôle d'un cheveu c'est sympa
obama antilles est entré au céleri que
vous ça va tu vas manquer alors ta
journée
ça a été dit walsh est une catastrophe
il a été sage et oui commenté me trouve
s'est toujours journaliste qui parle
mais j'ai déjà vu cet épisode se
trouvera compte pas la fin je regardais
déjà quand j'avais ton âge je vois tu me
parler de toi encore ça veut dire quoi
qu'ils fassent à nous faire la
conversation mais c'est toujours pour me
parler de toi le corps produit on peut
aussi parler toi quelle heure tu vas te
coucher je suis mort de rire
sauvé par le gong aubrac bien renchérit
il faut aller se coucher maintenant
aller au dodo
non non tu l'aimés peter pourquoi j'ai
tu n'aimes pas jeûner au sérieux on
dirait qu'il n'ya que lui qui
l'intéressent lui et la personne avec
qui il parle avec son stupide portable
je sais mais ne t'inquiète pas c'est toi
l'homme de ma vie
et si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waaa comme c'est romantique un dîner
sans vaisselle à faire je le prends
comme un compliment
[Musique]
mais si bien
je peux rester cette nuit pourquoi parce
que cette situation est trop déroutante
pour jacques le bihan des copains lui
qui viennent dormir ici des fois je suis
gêné je sais pas comment lui expliquer
notre relation c'est un peu confus je
sais pas comment je dois appeler devant
lui
et si tu compte rester longtemps et je
ne voudrais pas qu'il croit que tu es
ici à titre définitif si si c'est pas le
cas je pourrais partir avant l'aube ont
fait comme ça
car qu'est-ce que tu fais là tu te fais
partir l'objet je suis endormi je te
demande pardon tu sais lui toi toi
bonjour maman d'une petite honor
vicitmes vin bio valley en magnésium non
je ne regrette pas aujourd'hui si tu
veux tu viendras de bain j't'adore je la
tenais à badens du monde tu pourrais me
le dit aussi quand je te dis non voilà
c'est prêt non non c'est pas ma place
et oui je sais mais je me suis dit que
ce serait bien de mettre un peu de
variété dans ta vie par exemple changer
de place aux petits déjeuners cette
offre une nouvelle vue et peut-être mais
j'ai ma place habituelle si tu veux très
bien je peux te faire des propositions
mais je ne peux pas t'obliger à vouloir
changer
je n'ai pas obligés de rester avec moi
tu peux aller de préparer oui je sais je
sais mais mais pour une fois qu'on a
l'occasion de pouvoir faire quelque
chose ensemble comme par exemple lire la
notice du paquet de céréales
tu vois ça remonte à longtemps la
dernière fois qu'on l'a fait oui j'ai
fait toutes les bonnes vitamines callan
dans l'amant est ce que tu es sûr que
tout va bien
bien sûr bien sûr renchérit pourquoi
nisima pas aux nîmois qu'est ce que est
ce que tu as fait ton lit ce matin et
n'ont donc voilà en voilà une idée qui
est bonne
ce serait bien que tu fasses ton dit
tout de suite oui oui oui oui chéri tout
de suite si tu y tient et on se dépêche
allemand étudiera lot ne pas oublier son
costume de père noël
le ciel s'assombrit
ça veut dire que cette année on a un
noël blanc il est temps de rentrer à la
maison mais beauté
[Musique]
et si j'avais pu je me serais
transformée en petite souris je pourrais
peut-être mettre le costume et lui dire
que noël est arrivé avant il faudrait
qu'on explique à sac pourquoi on est
ensemble
non ce serait plutôt à moi qui est vrai
que tu m'explique
je regrette ce n'est ni lieu ni le
moment pour en discuter il faut que j'y
aille peter ça fait un an qu'on se
connaît et tu n'as jamais essayé de
sympathiser avec lui la portion c'est
pas fait pour les chiens se taisaient ça
pour rire
il s'agit de mon fils il
il fait partie de ma vie si tu veux
aussi en faire partie il faut que vous
soyez
et il faut vraiment que je me s'ouvre
sauf toi tu fais ça à merveille je suis
désolé
oh oh oh oh ça secoue dasher danseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
wright je sais les nids j'arrive tout
je pars tout de suite pas de problème
qu'est ce que c'est je te rappelle oh
mon dieu
monsieur
monsieur vous m'entendez
[Musique]
quel plus je déteste noël je déteste
noël se détestent
[Musique]
tuer tuer le père noël est ce que tu as
vu qu'il était mort tu vois bien qui
dort c'est grave
en tout cas il a une belle bosse sur le
front mais en dehors de ça n'a pas l'air
grave
tu vois je n'ai pas tué mais qui l'a
rudement sonné mais oui ce que tu
regardais quand tu l'a renversée j'en
sais rien il sortait de nulle part
il a une vraie barde n'y touche pas s'il
te plaît on va la lui laisser un
essayons de savoir qui il est il a
sûrement un portefeuille sur lui ah oui
bonne idée
[Musique]
les sucres d'orge des cookies
il reprend connaissance assez formidable
c'est vraiment très beaux jours comment
vous vous sentez vous venez d'avoir un
accident
oui vous êtes tombé devant ma voiture
c'est un menteur et un sens de la sphère
de grandes personnes en la fouiller dans
vos poches
on pensait qu'on ne trouverait des
papiers d'identité on pourrait appeler
quelqu'un de votre famille ou un ami
vous vous appelez comment et où
habitez-vous je suis peu parlé or oui
oui mais je je suis désolé je ne sais
vraiment pas quoi vous dire je vais vous
aider à vous rafraîchir la mémoire vous
avez un déguisement de père noël c'est
pour vous présenter un travail
vous croyez essai sera présenté à mon
travail par am en 2006 qu'il avait
vraiment envie de décrocher le poste et
il est venu jusqu'ici regarde son
costume et il est super bien il a l'air
très bien mon avis à mon avis tu devrais
l'embauché de terre évidemment je ne
peux pas décider à ta place mais je vous
prie de m'excuser vient d'une minute
s'il vous plaît
tu peux me dire à quoi tu jouais pas
j'essaie de résoudre ton problème est le
sien et il tient tu cherches un père
noël et cherche du boulot
t'as qu'à l'embauché tu as peur qu'il
porte plainte contre toi tu pourrais me
dire ce que les père noël tu ont fait à
chaque fois que tu en croise un tulle
massacre d'accord je me sens un peu
coupable je veux arranger le coup pour
lui mais tu peux pas dire le contraire
il est parfait peter c'est un mets ta
musique très bien il n'était pas tout à
fait parfait mais mais si ça se trouve
c'est pas ça chez imagine que cela dure
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ne recouvre pas
la mémoire et bien il se souviendra pas
que je les renverser
albright oui oui je paye être dans dix
minutes
d'accord qui arrive on m'appelle pour un
reportage
et tu te vois je suis désolé tu roberson
homme tu me les laissent dans mon
appartement et tout ce que tu trouve à
dire c'est je suis désolé il a l'air
d'un brave monsieur emmène le à ton
travail et je te contacterait plus tard
c'est ça et comme d'habitude tu te
sauver c'est à moi de me débrouiller je
savais que tu comprendrais je tends
vaudrait ça monsieur
ayez confiance à vous est au poil vous
serez choisi mais ça veut dire quoi être
au poil et bien vous est coachée par
film mais qu'est ce qu'il me veut je
n'en sais rien mais moi je sais que tu
es tu es le vrai père noël le père noël
qui sait 1
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais rien vu de plus étrange
de marchands les a trouvés dans l'enclos
un troupeau de rennes si ça se trouve
ils ont peut-être des noms bien là vixen
blixen comme elle la seule chose qui
nous manque c'est le trait nous ça alors
tu es un vrai de 20 attention on y va
doucement c'est bon j'arrête tout sonne
faux pas que ça leur tombe dessus
et vous avez vu d'où est arrivé le
prénom est ce tu rigoles d'arrivée de la
whl cette firme est qu'il est tombé du
ciel
la ville est victime d'un plaisantin qui
cherche à faire parler de lui pour noël
personne ne sait d'où proviennent ces
reines ont les amours et là c'est un
très bon ticket sur le cir trouver un
minot qui semble être tombé du ciel
dis moi c'est peau de monsieur de ce
matin c'était peter albright je vais
maintenant céder la parole à jenny pour
la météo merci peter
bien que nous ayons athiel de neige
comme on dit couramment pas le moindre
flocon à l'horizon
[Musique]
1 1
j'adore cette période de l'année qu'est
ce que vous aimez le plus à noël on sait
rien à vous ne devriez pas vous rangez
les ongles au désert et vous avez raison
mon
cela dit oh mercy claire a su faire le
costume je voterai pas mal non plus mais
gagner c'est trash et de fines et c'est
votre nouveau père noël on dirait que
vous êtes né pour ça merci je vous
souhaite bonne chance auxerre va gagner
au revoir merci monsieur dieu vous
bénisse
joyeux noël ap mennea faut-il que je
fasse un geste pas vous faites c'est
effrayant justement que fait le père
noël et bien il dit roro très souvent
enfin c'est ce que plutôt une sorte de
ne de rire tonitruant
ça va venir
c'est presque ça mademoiselle brière
candidats sont ils tous là et je crois
guère
palausse je n'étais pas dans le coup je
vous demande quelques secondes pour me
concentrer je recommence et bien été
gentils et ses luttes à l'être j'ai lu
deux fois j'ai suivi du pot norme chez
les bras en compote et après ça fait
faire du sport
à
je peux vous le faire aussi avec un
accent oh oh oh hé bien personnellement
j'ai trouvé le dernier plus tôt non non
non c'est rendront au moc énormément de
conviction non je trouve que le non sire
je trouve que le dernier comédien a
l'air beaucoup plus authentique à cause
de la barbe s'accorde une rouste à
mourir mademoiselle le père noël doit
aspirer la gaieté félicitations monsieur
en rouge c'est vous qui serez notre père
noël je comprends bien j'ai raté
l'audition sera great je suis désolé en
ami peter ne devrait pas tarder quand il
sera là on verra ce qu'on peut faire
pour vous en attendant hélène va vous
donner de l'argent pour que vous
puissiez aller déjeuner allez vous
acheter d'autres vêtements merci le
13ème
[Musique]
bonjour vous n'êtes pas au boulot et
bien faut croire que pour eux je n'étais
pas au poil ils sont aveugles ou core 3
vous trouverez une autre classe sociale
je l'espère je l'espère mais ça ne me
dérange pas d'être habillée comme ça
tout les jours au contraire j'adore ça
vous savez pour qui ça doit être dur
pour le vrai père noël
réfléchissez une seconde il est coincé
là bas au pôle nord il n'a pas la joie
de rencontrer les enfants
il lui est interdit d'assister aux
scènes de joie qu'ils provoquent ça
c'est un boulot pas facile en pub le
mans probable grady c'est bien ça brille
et vous êtes je suis perturbé très très
perturbé oui notre type offrirait pas
décrocher un poste c'est pas vrai tube
raison qu'il n'était pas assez exubérant
mais pour nous et en plus il a l'air
contagieux
[Musique]
ces blessés il faudra installer des
balustrades plus solide
ils font pas long feu chez vous les père
noël c'est toi qui l'a encore massacré
tuer le cauchemar des père noël
d'un autre côté le nôtre a enfin trouvé
un boulot
d'ailleurs il est au fait des courses
pourraient faire tu l'a envoyé tout seul
dans la nature mais où tu avais
l'envoyer s'acheter des vêtements il
peut rien lui être arriver quoi je n'ai
rien à voir là dedans votre barbe home
assuré chez le coiffeur qu une teinture
me rajeunir
vous me trouvez comment fait il vous
suffit de parler aux enfants de leur
faire de grands sourires aux et surtout
il faut que vous ayez les rejoignent eux
il faut quand votre présence les gens se
sentent bien afin qu'ils dépensent leur
argent non des cadeaux inutiles
il faut qu'ils ressentent la magie de
noël comme celle des pansements encore
plus d'argent dans les quatre minutes
est ce que vous avez pensé qu'on
pourrait donner tous ces cadeaux aux
enfants gratuitement les enfants se
réveillerait le matin noël et y trouvera
leurs cadeaux au pied du sapin ce génial
pourquoi l'idée a déjà été exploitée oui
c'est dommage
asseyez-vous c'est la première fois
qu'une chose pareille nous arrive
[Musique]
ah si
c'est bon tu dis quoi maintenant excusez
moi je passe c'était un fusible de
griller une prise défectueuse est réglé
maintenant ça devrait fonctionner est ce
que tu a commandé au père noël mais les
super geste mai à quillan week end je
savais qu'il serait parfait ouais mais
on sait toujours pas qui oui mais on va
le savoir à petit c'est que je déteste
quand tu as eu regard je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pas pensé avant j'étais
trop occupé avec cette histoire de
rennes et je me rendais pas compte que
je tenais un sujet en or
reconnaissez-vous ce père noël je vais
diffuser son image et il n'y aura pas un
seul téléspectateurs qui ne l'aura pas
fuir quand tu as l'intention de te
servir de ce pauvre monsieur quel pauvre
monsieur non tu te tombent sur mes
intentions
parmi les millions de gens qui nous
regardent peut-être quelqu'un le
reconnaître hâtive c'est ça aussi la
magie de noël faire en sorte que les
familles soient réunies que leur rêve se
réalise et à grimper l'audimat le faire
exploser
j'espère créer un grand élan de
solidarité les téléspectateurs feront
tout pour qu'il retrouve sa famille et
je serai présent avec ma caméra
oui ça fera un excellent un sujet
excellent j'espère casser la baraque
avec ce reportage
bonjour
qu'est ce qui te ferait plaisir pour
noël est-ce qu'il ya du nouveau et non
ils répondent pas son bip mais d'après
la balise il se trouverait dans cette
région cij très bien je veux les
meilleurs et les plus courageux d'entre
nous nous allons le récupérer mais si on
ne trouvait pas il faut le retrouver
sont obligés d'annuler noël j'écoute ce
que je dis il faut le retrouver
[Musique]
et
je vous souhaite un excellent séjour et
je vous remercie vous rentrez fêter noël
monsieur nax vous pouvez m'appeler max
max quelle est la raison de votre séjour
pour affaires
nous sommes ici pour faire je vois qu y
at il dans vos sacs
et alors
qui êtes vous les lutins du père noël
bienvenue dans 9 58 qui est il dans vos
sacs
ça vous intéresse
vous ne voulez pas qu'on jette un coup
d'oeil dans aussi pardon ouvrait ses
sacs
ne vous énervez pas art il je vais m'en
charger
[Musique]
jours
qu'y at il dans cet autre sac en des
articles de toilette brosse à dents
dentifrice
[Musique]
ted entier
allez-y à votre automne en passant vous
faire plaisir de vous moquer des
fonctionnaires les reprenez votre sac et
fichez moi le camp je ne veux plus vous
revoir dans les environs dégagé nous
retrouvons immédiatement peter hall
brahim qui est cet homme
vous allez tous me répondre que c'est le
père noël en fait cette personne est
amnésique nous ne connaissons pas son
identité et pourtant il a déjà touché le
coeur de milliers de gens cet homme
affable a mis de côté ses craintes et
ses incertitudes pour jouer le père noël
afin de se mettre au service des autres
sans penser à ces problèmes pendant
qu'ils offrent du bonheur aux petits
enfants cet homme vit un drame intérieur
il l'incarnation même de l'esprit de
l'autre toujours cette année d'offrir un
vrai cadeau au père noël
essayons de retrouver sa famille si l'un
ou l'une d'entre vous reconnaît sa
personne contactez-nous afin qu'ils
puissent passer noël auprès des siens on
ignore comment
non ça peut pas être lui ré morts c'est
vers nous et il va rependre la chambre
dira si l'un ou l'une d'entre vous
reconnais cette personne contactez-nous
afin qu'ils puissent passer noël auprès
des siens il a touché nos coeurs il est
l'incarnation de l'esprit de noël à
notre tour d'offrir un vrai cadeau père
noël ça va faire pleurer dans les
chaumières c'est bien libe tu as une
sacrée veine à chypre rien ce reportage
m'est tombé dessus sans jeu de mots à
l'échelle nationale vont reprendre ton
reportage demain je présente les infos
les soirs même un pas à la fois d'abord
retrouve moi qui ait ce bonhomme il me
reste 48 heures si je veux que cet homme
passent le réveillon en famille à
s'il vous plaît soyez mail douteux
et laissez nous passer
ici
là un peu de calme c'est
[Applaudissements]
je vous demandais un peu d'ordre local
vous passerez tous chacun votre tour
je vous dis que ce portrait contrat
chômeurs etc soirée par conséquent je
suis en droit de lui réclamer si dans
deux ponts sur les moteurs évidemment
chez un vieux copain du père henri et
vous êtes je suis le lièvre
je connaissais mon frère nous sert
gimont
[Applaudissements]
évidemment nous sommes dues faujour est
ce qui est une récompense avec les mêmes
une toute petite minute maudite d'une
ensemble ce soir passé ce soir je
regrette j'ai eu une journée harassante
et j'aimerais pouvoir passer un peu de
temps avec 5
on va au cinéma voir miracle sur la 34e
rue tu veux venir non c'est gentil ce
soir il faudrait peut-être que je
m'occupe un peu de notre ami ce sera
pour une autre fois bien dans ce cas je
te laisse que pensez-vous de ma
prestation
elle est il par excellence et bien vous
venez dormir chez moi non je voudrais
pas m'imposer le compte ainsi six ans je
peux pas vous laisser dans la nature
vous êtes mauvais pas je n'ai pas le
souvenir d'avoir jamais reçu un salaire
pour un travail que je commence à en
avant vous travaillez gratuitement
là j'en sais rien mais c'est la première
fois que je gagne autant d'argent
tension arrêter de montrer vos billets
dans la roi c'est mal non mais parce
qu'enfin tout le monde n'est pas aussi
gentil coup et alors quelqu'un pourrait
vous le volet quelqu'un pourrait faire
savoir s'il vous plaît rangez les dans
votre poche à nous aimer les marrons
chauds et j'en sais rien j'en sais rien
je sais rien attaquer
excusez-moi pernaut c'est formidable on
dirait que tout le monde a envie de
s'amuser la période de l'année qui
fiscaux noël si spécial par rapport aux
autres films ont dépassé
vous voyez les gens sont vraiment
sympathiques reste à côté de cette
excuse en l'air heureux c'est pas le cas
tu disputes de beaucoup plus tard au web
et du siec être faite l'écho pas avancer
et vous
c'est inévitable pourtant claire a l'air
d'une charmante personne
ah oui elle est charmante mais elle
attend plus de moi c'est chez mal que ça
vous avait été mariée j'en sais rien du
tout alors c'est non ça s'oublie pas moi
ce qui me gêne c'est l'idée de devenir
d'un seul coup chef de famille c'est à
cause du petit rat vous n'aimez pas les
enfants non j'ai rien contre les enfants
mais j'aime mieux les voir chez les
autres
pourtant ils ne sont pas différentes
vous et moi ils sont comme nous ils sont
juste un peu plus petits mais ils sont
plus futés que nous plus futés y voit
des choses que nous les adultes nous ne
voyons plus quand vous avez autant de
choses sur les enfants a franchement
j'en sais rien mais ça a l'air sensés
pour vrai ça nous arrivait à cet essai
aux habiter dans un chouette immeuble
merci vous
cheminées et la tension commençait à la
merci peter ho c'est beau vous avez des
enfants
non non je ne me souviens pas d'un
enfant particulier mais j'ai le souvenir
de plaintes petite personne pas de sapin
j'ai pas eu le temps or mais vous avez
pensé aux cadeaux oui bien sûr j'ai
acheté ça pour ça qu à aa
l'histoire du père noël ça vous dit
quelque chose
et ça c'est pour les autres des
catalogues vous offrez des catalogues
nord je commande ce qu'il me demande
j'ai fait mes achats de noël ont une
heure et demie cette année j'ai battu
mon record je comprends pas qu'il ne me
reste qu'un souvenir de noël
peter et si vous m'appreniez l'un de ces
chants de noël vous ne vous souvenez
d'aucun chants de noël j'ignore même si
je sais chanter
de bon matin j'ai rencontré le train de
droit d'en haut à qui allaitent envoya
de bon matin j'ai rencontré le fin de
trois grands rois dessus le grand mas aa
je connait enfin jean noël je vous
réponde renault annonce demain
maintenant il est l'heure d'aller se
coucher à g revient à tout ça
[Musique]
si vous voulez je peux vous prêter un
pyjama
bonjour merci j'ai ce qu'il faut mais
bien peu nuit
[Musique]
le détecteur s'affole complètement
regarder si son traîneau oui mais il
n'est pas là ni lui ni ses rêves venez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je lui ai dit mme il faut toujours
garder sa balise sur lui il ne m'est
coûterait donc jamais en tout cas nous
avons retrouvé son traîneau on s'en va
où veux tu qu'on aille max nous allons
fouiller la ville toute la ville max
mais cette ville et si gand
de bon matin j'ai rencontré le pain des
trois grands rois qui elle est en rodage
de bon matin j'ai encontre il tend un
deux trois croix dessus leurs enjeux
vous me voyez un autre champ lalalalala
lui la résine et chantant 1,4 alors là
mon boss alalalala l'arrêt c'est bon
c'est bon arrêtez s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on pourrait discuter discuter ah oui
vous savez des paroles sans musique
vous savez bien sûr c'est possible on
peut discuter oui ah c'est bien c'est
super c'est super ouais enfin qui sait
c'est peut être le grand jour pour vous
vous chanterez ces chants de noël en
compagnie de votre famille vous le
pensez vraiment on peut toujours
l'espérer
connaissez-vous cet homme le compte à
rebours a commencé
il ne restera que 36 heures series est
fou avant ne puisse passer le réveillon
de noël en compagnie de sa femme le mien
tu ne trouves pas qui ressemble un terme
l'une d'entre vous reconnaissez receveur
il a disparu depuis dix ans ah c'est
vrai lui ressemble beaucoup appelé le
standard de la chaîne 12 à notre numéro
gratuit que 5 5 5 à 2 3 4 mais vous
pouvez aussi le contact et à toute heure
sur notre site internet
alors oui on s'appelle au sujet de la
personne les rues tous un joyeux oui je
crois l'avoir identifié des pères noël à
tous les coins de rue max oui mais nous
ne recherchons qu'un second celui là
pour ça
nous recherchons le vrai haut c'est bien
pensé max week
j'ai eu avec l'ère virtuelle de génie tu
es le plus intelligent de tous max walla
commissaire merci avez vous une piste
nous avons dû interroger au moins 200
personnes mais seuls deux pistes
semblent sérieuses qui veut dire que
tous les autres n'étaient que des
timbres et ça change quoi pour toi
il est obligé d'être là oui écoutez
monsieur le bras monsieur le mans est la
solution que je préconisais de le
présenter notre psy cat de service et de
l'interroger sous hypnose
vous croyez à ce genre de vieux trucs
nous obtenons parfois de bons résultats
oui il faut le faire on sera fixé
[Musique]
imaginez que vous êtes chez vous et que
vous êtes en toute sécurité et que
quelqu'un vous appelle il s'agit d'une
voix féminine
mon épaule oui votre épouse nick bien
comment s'appelle votre femme mode homme
et avec ça on risque d'aller très très
loin c'est parfait nick pouvez vous me
décrire votre intérieur
il fait froid dehors c la nuit et
comment vous occupez vous je donne à
manger aux animaux
quels animaux oh je n'en suis pas sûr
des shows n'y a t'il d'autres personnes
autour de vous peut-être des enfants oh
oui je vois des enfants à moins que ce
ne soit le petit bonhomme des petits
pose à de petits ben ça c'est très flou
ce n'est pas grave nick mairie
que se passe t-il dit man vous êtes je
suis debout sur sur le toit d'une maison
qu'est ce que vous faites
je suis en train de tomber non c'est pas
ça du tout je vois non c'est impossible
je ne peux pas je veux descendre je veux
rentrer chez moi attendu détendez vous
vous allez atterrir tout en douceur et
lorsque j'aurai compté jusqu'à 3 vous
vous réveillerez leur ai aucun souvenir
de notre conversation
[Musique]
et vous vous sentirez frais et dispos
une des trois alors comment cela s'est
il passé c'est en qui je suis oui tu es
pire noël
c'était pourtant clair nous ne savons
toujours pas qui vous êtes mais nous
avons de nouveaux indices c'est pourtant
facile des animaux des petits bonshommes
il vole c'est évident en hausse il te
plaît ce monsieur est il vrai père noël
claire qui dois bien me souvenir de
quelque chose claire monsieur le spi
voudrais que vous descendiez la foulée
complètement oui j'étais seulement une
minute merci s'il te plaît est ce que je
peux te demande est occupé de sac
maintenant je n'en aurai pas pour
longtemps rends-toi utile pour une fois
d'accord si j'avais la possibilité de
multiplier les séances je pourrais
l'aider progressivement à ce qu'il
recouvre la mémoire
mais ce qui pourrait provoquer chez lui
déclic serait un choc émotionnel le fait
de revoir un lieu ou un visage familier
n'importe quoi qui pourrait lui rappeler
qu'il est nous allons déjà commencé par
prendre un nouveau rendez vous en
attendant je veux que nous poursuivions
les interrogatoires très bien contacté
massacres inter ce serait bien que vous
puissiez l'identifier le plus vite
possible et j'ai promis à mes
téléspectateurs qu'il passerait le
réveillant avec sa famille pour moi le
plus important est de retrouver sa vraie
famille
oui effectivement vous avez vos
priorités et moi je vais l'envoyer nulle
part puisqu'il s'y perdre aux attaques
soient gentils c'est une affaire qui
concerne les adultes contente toi de
rester avec nick commissaire fait une
bonne idée le réveillon de noël ces deux
mots et si d'ici là tu te rappelles pas
qui tu es alors quoi que se passera-t-il
il se passe car bien c'est justement ça
le problème
il n'y aura pas de cadeau de noël
il faut que tu te rappelles qui tu es
c'est la seule solution à tout à l'heure
le psychiatre a dit qu'il me fallait un
choc émotionnel ici troubles suis moi
[Musique]
dépêche-toi balle arrive je vous
tiendrai au courant en fait merci
commissaire ils sont partis par l'ars
pour une fois qu'elle me demande de
veiller sur son fils voulait laisser
filer
il est en sécurité il était avec un
adulte l'adulte qui ignore son nom et
d'où il vient tu vois ton ce résultat le
travail pour toi et tu possèdes des
rêves et tu atterris sur les toits ouais
ouais j'ai des 100 pages chinois oui ça
ne te dit rien non je suis désolé
et comment s'appelle ce film déjà il
s'appelle la vie est belle alors
pourquoi le héros va t-il se suicider me
regarde et me rassure la 34e route
pourquoi t-il au tribunal
les gens croient tilly fois
est ce le père noël pourquoi volts ils
tous les jouets l'ocldi au regard si
rudolf c'est warren préférées alors
pourquoi il a un nez de clown souvient
vraiment de rien mais will rain
oh oui j'ai dit viens avec moi soyez
vigilants il peut être partout alors
ouvrez l'oeil et le bon on a compris max
[Musique]
bon récapitulons le père noël se
déplacent entraîneur oh oui
des lutins travaille pour lui oui il
atterrit sur les trois oui ils
descendent par la cheminée vie vous
voyez où je veux en venir
non moi non plus on s'en va vous me
recevait à quoi est-ce que vous rêvez on
a le mal du pays réfléchit un attelage
de rennes le père noël
le très lourd non je ne reconnais pas
ces animaux vraiment au caire mais
est-ce que tu as encore d'autres idées
maurice tu es ce que strelok te dit
quelque chose non
ah ah
et regarde des prêts dressé au père noël
samedi toujours rien
[Musique]
je suis sûr de neige et jour de l'an et
bolton et grand-mère h de route connaît
au peter mes personnages cloche à vous
aussi je te quitte des yeux 30 secondes
et tout ce que tu trouves à faire ses
filets tu m'a dit de rester avec mx et
ça joue sur les mots je confirme j'ai ce
que vous lui avez dit à pour ça vous
n'êtes pas amnésiques
tu sais très bien que tu ne devais pas
tant d'années j'étais vraiment inquiet
tu avais peur de quoi
que ma mère tes fiches une raclée à ses
statuts étaient enfuis dans l'attention
de me nuire aux noms et c'était pour
aider nique
je pense vraiment que tu es le centre du
monde aussi j'ai envie de lui venir en
aide
ce n'est pas vrai c'est vrai mais c'est
la structure non c'est faux j'en pense
juste que tu adieu au commissaire tu as
dit que tu t'en fiches et où il irait ou
avec qu'il partirait tout ce qui
comptait c'était de reportages et père
noël est ce que je peux tu parler bien
sûr que tu peux parler bien sûr mes
genoux et raconte moi tout ma jolie
nahla
tu sais qui est un joli personne n'a
jamais fait remarquer tu trouves que je
ne l'êtes pas je fais tout pour qu'il
retrouve à foyer un vrai mais il a déjà
en foyer libye au pôle nord et il faut
qu'il y retourne avant le réveillon en
attendant c'est toi qui vas rentrer à la
maison qui n'a pas l'air de 34 cause de
toi tu va gâcher le noël du monde en
tout ça parce que je veux que tu rentres
à la maison
non parce que tu refuse d'écouter tu
m'écoutes jamais ni moi ni maman et tu
sera incapable de reconnaître le vrai
père noël même s'il sortirait sur
l'amour du ciel zac le père noël est une
invention ce monsieur ne peut pas être
le père noël
[Musique]
oui j'étais quand même l avion mais il
ne faut pas être égoïste
il faut que tu apprennes à partager
d'esprit qu'elle poivey ce qu il te
faudrait
[Musique]
albright clair oui zac est avec moi et
ils sont tous les deux avec moi à oui
j'ai eu la situation bien en main oui
oui mais bien mais il voulait écouter
les chants de noël excuse moi tu
interrompre oui il faut que je te laisse
les chanteurs vont se mettre en place et
très bien alors à tout à l'heure où
emmener vos ce traîneau à la halle aux
jouets le maire veut qu'on expose là bas
ni xaxi loupe l'aide des 110 de la puce
ou les mélanges pas on va pas très loin
et puis je vais rouler doucement
[Musique]
excusez-moi ac
tu ne veut toujours pas rentré à la
maison nos fils et en présence d'objets
de visages familiers il lui faut à
chaque est possible je t'en prie zac ne
fait pas l'imbécile c'est ce que les
psychiatres hadzic n'était pas pour tous
les âges et assurer les trop âgé pour ce
travail là dedans tu rigoles ou quoi
regarde le peter et je voudrais même
site remercier pour tous les continents
et qu'est ce que je t'ai offert et bien
je n'ai plus vraiment toute ma tête en
ce moment tu sais que ce n'est pas grave
a toujours nommé participer oui je
comprends ce que tu veux dire
albright ici le commissaire mais sur le
bright
je voulais vous dire que nous tenons
enfin une piste sérieuse oui ce serait
ses petits enfants selon leur grand père
aurait disparu sans laisser de traces
et ils m'ont apporté une photo de lui
notre infographiste la retravailler et
avec une barbe et dix ans de plus qu'il
ne ressemble à l'autre
vous aurez de certains et bien à l'heure
actuelle nous effectuons quelques
recherches complémentaires mais je
jurerais que celle oui oui eh eh bien
c'est à dire que pendant une fraction de
seconde je me suis dit que peut-être
[Musique]
c'est pas grave j'arrive tout de suite
finalement vous allez la voir votre
scoop cela devrait vous réjouir
un ça de vrai
vous m'avez dit que votre grand père a
disparu il ya dix ans oui il ya dix ans
il se rendait à notre salle des fêtes le
soir de noël pour jouer le père noël
avec le déguisement mais ne l'ont jamais
vu arriver depuis la disparue on n'a
plus jamais entendu parler de lui quand
pourrons-nous ne voir et bien sûr les
informations concordent vous le verrez
demain vous voulez bien nous excuser une
minute
vous voudriez me faire croire que ça
fait dix ans que nick se baladant père
noël qui sait le g d'autres indices
nicolas engel a grandi dans une ferme en
norvège le plus jeune d'une famille de
douze enfants des animaux le froid
beaucoup d'enfants a émigré dans les
années 40 et a été pilote de bombardier
durant la guerre donc il a volé oui il
semblerait que vous teniez enfin votre
bien
[Musique]
j'écoute voix se passe devant le
tribunal premièrement tu t'en vas avec
sachs on me dire quoi que ce soit et
ensuite les abandonnent tous les deux
dans la rue et tu voudrais que je sois
ravi écoute je suis pas d'humeur à
discuter je viens chercher nique et on
s'en va
nick j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
il semblerait que la police y retrouver
qui vous étiez séparé et alors comment
est-ce que je m'appelle nicolas engel
chevaux vivait chez votre petite fille
vous retourner chez elles demain c'est
pas possible puisque c'est le père noël
sac
si tu l'emmènes il n'y aura plus jamais
de noël ça tu veux arrêter ces sottises
je t'ai dit que le père noël n'existait
samedi je te dis que non ce n'est pas
lui c'est un vieux monsieur amnésique
écouter et ça suffit tous les deux
[ __ ] bien en ce à quoi tu te conduis
comme un gamin c'est lui qui se comporte
justement c'est un enfant mais toi c'est
quoi ton excuses ne vous inquiétez pas
de risques et je ne te permets pas
d'élever la voix contre monfils
il faut bien que quelqu'un lui fasse
entendre raison tu crois que c'est sain
de le laisser croire qu'un vieux
monsieur est le père d'horaire qui tue
pour le dire ce qu'il faut croire toi
qui as peur de croire en quoi que ce
soit fait que lui dire la vérité je ne
vais pas besoin d'être aussi dure et
bien il s'en remettra j'ai connu ça
c'est donc ça la raison monsieur a eu
une enfance malheureuse alors il s'en
prend à mon fils
pardon tu n'as jamais pu l'oublier peter
tu es tellement coincé dans ton passé
que tu es incapable de songer à un
avenir et et à notre avenir
maintenant j'en ai la certitude quelles
certitudes
je sais que je n'ai rien à attendre de
toi c'est fini tu le pense vraiment
aïe
parfait
parfait tout bien
alors c'est fini
si l'on ne compte pas suffisamment pour
toi autant que tu nous oublie
[Musique]
venez unique on s'en va tant pis il va
falloir qu'on rentre chez doublet mais
malheureusement le taux nous fait défaut
notre devoir est de sauver noël au prix
d'abandonner le père noël y at il un
endroit nous n'avons pas fouillé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a l'air perdu je trouve
on ne peut pas conduire le traîneau si
on a oublié la route et votre petite
fille non la salle des fêtes de votre
quartier
olemps tout sereine vous dit rien du
tout non peut-être que lorsque je la
verrai en tout cas vous serez chez vous
pour le réveillon me et vous serez où je
devais le passé avec claire mais c'est
fini
ce n'est pas à cause de moi j'espère non
non ça devait arriver un jour ou l'autre
je ne sais pas me prendre avec les
enfants vous vous êtes hfe
on met tous ses enfants cet après-midi
était vraiment formidable ah ah j'avais
oublié oublier quoi je l'ignorent vous
voyez comment je suis je suis incapable
de me souvenir de ce que je veux oublier
et c'est sûr après vous souvenir vous
reviendront pas manille à peter venez
donc vous asseoir avec moi s'il vous
plaît je ne vais pas vous m'enlevez et
venez lire si vous venez
ah je veux vous faire la lecture c'est
comme ça qu'on aide les petits enfants
alice coucher et bien c'était la nuit de
noël il n'y avait pas un bruit dans la
maison tout le monde était endormie pas
même une petite souris qui prenait les
choses cet été délicatement accroché au
manteau de la cheminée dans l'espoir que
le père noël ou syndicaux là comme on
l'appelle dans certains pays ferait
bientôt sa tournée les enfants étaient
bien au chaud sous leurs couvertures et
il rêvait de maisons en sucres d'orge de
sentiers pavé de chocolat
[Musique]
vous
faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
à
ah vous le savez pas qui ça devenait dur
pour le vrai père noël les enfants
il m'est interdit d'assister aux scènes
de joie qu'ils provoquent
ça c'est un boulot pas facile mais le
football est en retard vous êtes en
retard
vous êtes vous êtes encore tous ces
retards
vous êtes
pourquoi en retard cher père noël tu es
meilleur
tout ce que je sais pas c'est un joyeux
noël en compagnie d'une famille qui
m'aime je t'embrasse peter albright
peter a dû terminer ta lettre
oui tenait la voici peter je viens
d'avoir roger au téléphone et j'ai le
regret d'annoncer qu'il ne viendra pas
de chercher des bobos
il a dit qu'il ne viendrait pas et le
père noël
il ne viendra pas lui non plus
[Musique]
ça ne va pas ah oui oui ça va mais j'ai
fait un rêve extrêmement bizarre avec
moi aussi figurez-vous je pourrais bien
avait fait un verre de lait bien servi
et de quoi avez vous rêvé à j'ai rêvé
que j'étais en retard que c'était
vraiment affreusement en retard pour lui
le quelque chose
les cauchemars où le temps vous échappe
ça m'arrive souvent et vous de quoi avez
vous rêvé de mon orphelinat là où j'ai
grandi
un orphelinat oui ma mère est morte
quand j'avais 7 ans et mon père ne
sentais pas la fibre paternelle
j'étais pour lui une sorte de boulet
s'est rêvé du premier noël que j'ai
passé là bas
le noël où j'ai cessé de croire au père
noël j'étais en train de lui écrire je
ne sais même plus ce que je lui avais
demandé comme cadeau que vous vouliez
passer un joyeux noël en compagnie d'une
famille qui vous est mais c'est ça
comment avez vous deviné je suppose que
c'est le souhait de la plupart du petit
orphelin sûrement
c'est ce jour là que j'avais sans regret
et à jeter mal être dans le feu alors je
me suis dit que si elle faisait soeur
brenta était-elle danoise où le
norvégienne c'est pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya une coutume norvégienne qui consiste
à jeter les lettres destinées au père
noël dans le foyer de la cheminée une
légende prétend que la fumée en portera
ainsi les lettres vers le pôle nord
beaucoup plus vite qu'en savez vous je
ne saurais pas vous le dire
ah ah en tout cas ça n'a pas marché
bon soit il n'a pas été exaucé peut-être
n'est-il pas trop tard
je ne vois pas fondant une famille
pourtant vous feriez un très bon papa
peter ça n'arrivera pas claire ne veut
plus entendre parler de moi et zach
pense que je suis le grinch qui a
bousillé noël quoique vous aison vous
avez beaucoup plus de points communs que
vous ne le croyez
c'est incroyable pour quelqu'un qui a
perdu la mémoire vous en savait long sur
moi eh bien peut-être que tous les deux
nous avons besoin de nous souvenir de
l'homme que nous étions s'il avait
quelques années en moins je jurerais que
vous êtes le père noël
[Musique]
m
nick
[Musique]
il faut qu'on n'y rien
et
il est difficile de croire que cela ne
fait que trois jours que nous avons
rencontré notre ami nick mais je suis
heureux de vous annoncer que cette
histoire va se terminer comme un conte
de fées la nuit dernière le département
de police a retrouvé qui était notre
père noël il s'appelle nicolas engels sa
petite fille et son mari n'avait jamais
perdu espoir de retrouver un jour leur
grand-père qu'ils aimait tant et voilà
que ce jour tente michu raconte sa
petite fille et son mari sont venu le
rechercher
je veux lui au moins ses petites-filles
la retourner à aa
[Musique]
c'est le miracle de noël voici une
famille à nouveau réunis c'était peter
albright pour la chaîne 12
merci leur a dit oui c'est moi coller
une félicitation
désormais je n'aurai plus besoin de se
costumer fort de vous laisser vous êtes
sûr vous le méritez amplement ça alors
merci collègues et joyeux noël et noël à
vous peter est cuite
merci pour tout ce que vous avez acheté
ici pour rien j'aimerais toutefois
pouvoir vous offrir
on vous avait déjà fait beaucoup pour
moi
si les prenais mon portable votre
portable comme ça je pourrai toujours
avoir d'or à ces gentils au clair
vous pouvez être très fiers de votre
petit garçon bien de voir ça que je
voudrais parler
tiens je vais m'asseoir il va avant tout
chanter tu sais je suis très content de
ce qui m'arrive j'ai retrouvé ma famille
je vais retourner auprès des miens
elle stocke ses adorables de ta part
d'avoir cru que j'étais le vrai père
noël a aussitôt pris tu vas me manquer
[Musique]
au revoir
attention à la marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je serais heureuse qu'on attendait d'eux
des fêtes sera passée il n'y aura pas de
noël au il te manque à moi aussi
il sera mieux dans sa famille tu sais
oui mais je t'ai tonnes pas si la terre
entière se réveille sans cadeaux de noël
et si on passait cette journée ensemble
rien que toi et moi d'accord allait bien
je prends ma journée mais c'est la
veille de noël notre plus gros chiffre
d'affaires de l'année je sais ben tu
l'as dit joyeux noël à vous aussi et
merci mon bonhomme estime pouvoir
parfaitement exactement ma taille j'ai
trouvé quelque chose il ya des poches
secrète un peu partout j'ai retrouvé ses
lettres il faudrait les lui rendre
maman c'était cliché un père noël et il
regarde ses lettres et des dans l'une de
ses poches qui d'autre que le père noël
norris sur lui des lettres adressées au
père noël
elio m'avait aussi dans le traîneau ac
arrête d'ennuyer peter tut voit très
bien qu'il n'a pas envie qu'on le
dérange
alors où tu veux aller à la halle où
jouer
je
[Musique]
et
je
on
[Musique]
cher père noël tu es le meilleur
tout ce que je sais pas si un joyeux
noël en compagnie d'une famille qui
m'aime je t'embrasse
robin wright
c'est impossible comment a t-il eu cette
lettre
[Musique]
tu va enfin faire de bons repas le
dimanche fait du rôti de porc lundi du
thon en sauce mardi du rosbif mercredi
le plat préféré de rennes ne l'a pas la
moutarde jeudi des escalopes milanaises
c'est toi qui sonne grand père
excusez-moi appuyé sur le bouton vert
quand r oui allô allô clic
peter j'aimerais savoir où où vous avez
eu ses lettres à quelle lettre les
lettres adressées au père noël elle
était dans vos poches
j'ai un peu de mal à m'en souvenir je
crois que j'étais en train de les lire
avant que ce sont des lettres des
enfants de l'orphelinat où j'ai grandi
il ya celle de bobby et celle de chad et
et la mienne mais vous ne m'avez pas
nicolas sar avait brûlé la lettre dans
la cheminée
je sais et bien alors personne ne
pourrait détenir cette lettre oui c'est
exact
personne sauf
le père noël le père noël
[Musique]
noël 1 c'est impossible c'est la seule
réponse vous êtes sûrement le père noël
écoutez pouvez-vous me retrouver à à la
halle aux jouets dans un quart d'heure
alors à fait est ce qu'on pourrait faire
un petit détour par la loge où et
pourquoi il ya un problème
j'ai un achat de dernière minute à faire
[Musique]
tu cherches quelque chose en particulier
jerry le trine
à l'eau claire c'est toi qu'est ce que
tu veux je voudrais parler à zac
d'accord peter voudrais te parler je
n'ai pas le temps il n'a pas envie de te
parler
dis-lui simplement je veux que tu lui
dises dis lui que je le crois
[Musique]
la menace du passant
ce que tu fais
et on
[Musique]
bitar temps reportage c'est du tonnerre
j'ai un meilleur scoop emporte le
matériel
au finish faire le malin pardon
qu'avez-vous fait du père noël
mais qui êtes vous au total de malades
attendent à celui-là je savais qu'il y
avait encore d'autres lettres
je veux que tu redescends tout de suite
j'ai les lettres les lettres ces trois
billets traitant et puis les raids
il n'y a pas doute nickel au père noël
je savais que tu fabriques
c'est la phrase que twitter pense
exactement comme toi par cibray wii sega
surtout ne bougez pas ne fait plus un
geste
rassurez vous je vais te tuer ne bouge
pas
est-ce que ça va à peter a oui bien sûr
je suis enchanté d'avoir été pris en
otage par une bande de drôle de petit
bonhomme avec des vêtements de toutes
les couleurs petit mot qui vous êtes des
lutins des lutins vous avez vu nos
oreilles
c'est pas du toc elles sont vraies tu as
touché jackpot mon gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Musique]
manger surtout ne bougez pas gauche
molle
l'homme a doucement approche vers notre
approche
ça va aller ça va aller nouveau
cauchemar
dans une seconde je serai avec toi
les concernant
hu
[Musique]
ce n'est pas encore ça va bien se passer
j'ai la situation tout devrait bien se
passer je suis sur wii aussi sûr que je
suis là
pas à la
finalement ce n'est peut-être pas ton
grand père c'est waterloo
sharifi si oui oui c'est moi je suis le
père noël
[Musique]
où
j'ai ici
excusez-moi père noël père noël on
dirait qu est ce que vous avez fait
votre bar le tapis je me sens un autre
homme
vous avez aussi l'apparence d'un autre
homme match je sais que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui j'en ai l intime
conviction il aime toujours autant père
noël je vais reprendre du service
oui mais va falloir vous dépêcher à
parce que le réveillon
c'est ce soir c'est ce soir le réveillon
mais je suis en retard pour me tourner
on n'arrivera jamais à livrer tous les
jouets à temps plus vite nous sommes en
retard et wim jonk sapin c'est de
l'autre côté que vous allez ne connais
pas de chemin c'est un raccourci c'est
ça vous le voulez pour les touristes ah
ah ah voilà j'ai compris je récapitule
vous êtes le père noël et les chercher
pour être oui c'est exact et où sont les
petits lutins envahissant la l1 libre
[Musique]
il ya deux solutions la méthode forte
j'attire quand tu veux max ou la méthode
douce dans les mois les plus chauds clé
le ciel est à nous ou la police
on est en train d'attaquer le marchand
de sapins de noël c'est le père noël et
ses lutins qui veulent récupérer leurs
rêves et à l'eau et à l'eau
et on dirait que ce soir on va aller
faire une petite balade tout le monde se
retourne sans faire de gestes brusques
[Musique]
à
ne jouez pas les héros mon vieux
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous attendez il faut y
aller mais on va être en sûrs georges il
vaut mieux se retrouver là bas mais
comment allez-vous rentrer en première
classe mais le film en exclusivité de la
nourriture à volonté et cacahuètes au
bon dieu
on y va attacher à ces partis dans une
serre en route pour la tournée
[Musique]
au gymnase
m
adorant vas-y toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zac tu sais la lettre que j'avais écrite
elle est écrite quand j'avais à peu près
ton âge et ça m'a permis de me rendre
compte que nous avions des points
communs tous les deux oui il est qu'elle
est bien par exemple d'être papa du
manque beaucoup à tous les deux
et tous les deux nous aimons beaucoup ta
maman et nous croyons tous les deux au
père noël tu as absolument raison tu
crois mythe maintenant tu lui coûtera
oui je te promets et tu mettras jamais
ma parole en 12
il faudrait pas exagérer
[Applaudissements]
comme vaut cet honneur
je te demande pardon
non c'est moi non c'est moi qui ai
football pardon intention c'est ça oui
tout ça
qui avait raison
je ne conduisais comme un enfant
[Musique]
excepté que l'épousé
tu es sérieux ouais
ça ne gêne pas d'être le père d'une
famille recomposée c'est justement ce
que je désire une vraie famille
à
[Applaudissements]
on souhaite noël vient enfin
mais
hahaha
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis content de vous voir
avez vous toujours le costume que je
vous avais au fait oui il est dans ma
voiture pouvait le moment je vous le
site pas nous allons avoir un noël blanc
oui finalement tout s'arrose
dépêchez-vous gaudi de voix lasse il
fait alors c'est vous le vrai père noël
oui elle est bien agathois dire ça ça
veut dire que j'ai mis costume du père
noël
il faut que je le dise à la fin ils sont
forcés gradé g berne aurait il se fait
tard si on veut y arriver il va nous
falloir un miracle
will et tu as raison le moment est venu
de faire appel à la magie de noël
[Musique]
oui mais comment pour fo tu aimerais
bien le savoir n'est ce pas peter je
suis affreusement retard cette année
est-ce que vous accepteriez de me donner
un petit coup de main écoutez unique
c'est une offre qu'il est difficile de
refuser mais ça fait si longtemps que
j'espérais pouvoir passer le réveillon
de noël en famille à c'était la réponse
que je souhaitais entendre c'était celle
que je souhaitais entendre aussi nous
sommes en retard pour les cinq fuseaux
horaires ne l'avons pas une seconde à
perdre
à bientôt
[Musique]
ah ah
c'était le vrai père noël incroyable non
c'est ce que nous pensons aussi et vous
me direz qu'on peut croire que ce convoi
alors nous allons conclure cette édition
du sport avec ses sur balles en six
manches
là c'était bizarre c'est vrai tout ça
incroyable un très joyeux noël
le mieux ce sera
[Musique]
grand père
je suis un petit peu en retard on
appelle plus a du retard il faut y aller
joyeux noël
[Musique]
chers internautes merci pour avoir
exercé mon souhait je vous embrasse
picard albright
[Musique]
bien à madame
oui c'est moi qui marque
[Musique]
et
père noël j'ai deux mois mais joyeux non
votre sac
là
[Musique]